about this talk of course is that if
anything goes wrong failure is always an
option so i'll be like it's right there
in the title what were you expecting uh
but yeah we're going to talk about
failure
because uh
failure is kind of a bad word right
like you go through school you go
through your exams like did you pass or
did you fail what happened oh the
project failed this thing didn't work
failure has this incredibly negative
connotation about it and what i want to
do
in the next hour or so is i want to look
at failure and the way that we
understand it the way that we anticipate
it the things that we do
to uh kind of work with the concept of
failure in the systems that we build my
name is dylan beatty
i've been building websites since the
1990s i've been building distributed
systems i've been using.net since uh i
got visual studio beta on a dvd at a
microsoft press event in redmond i've
been building so i'm basically an
internet dinosaur uh i run a company
called versatile in london that does uh
software training and strategy and stuff
uh i'm a microsoft mvp i'm a run the
london.net user group i once invented a
programming language in a bar as a joke
which i'm sure some of you may have
heard about because the internet quite
likes it it is the language called
rockstar all of your rockstar programs
are also heavy metal songs so if it
doesn't compile you can still sing it
and uh as i mentioned to some of you who
are in the talk added earlier um because
of rockstar now people on linkedin no
longer advertise for rockstar
programmers which i think is kind of
nice now the title of this talk
is a kind of adaptation of a very famous
line from this movie apollo 13. uh
there's a scene in this now i'm not
going to give the ending away one the
movie's been at for like 30 years and
two it was based on a true story but
it's about a bunch of astronauts who go
into space uh they're on the way to the
moon the ship blows up it looks like
they're all gonna die and then they
don't die and they get them back and
everyone goes yay america is amazing and
uh there is a scene there you go that's
apollo 13 like 20 words um there's a
very famous scene in this movie where
uh this character this is the mission
director gene krantz he's played by ed
harris in the movie and he comes out
with this memorable line failure is not
an option
now he didn't actually say that or
rather he did say it but he didn't say
it back in
1961 when apollo 13 was 1960 71 when
apollo 13 was happening for real um he
said it
in an interview with the people who
wrote the movie in about 1995. they went
and talked to uh so the filmmakers went
and talked to all the people who were
involved with the apollo 13 mission and
at some point in this interview
apparently crown said you know we knew
we realized then that failure was not an
option and the screenwriters look at
each other and go that's it that's the
strap line for the movie right there and
uh he liked it so much that after the
movie came out he then took that same
line and used it as the title of his
autobiography
but you know failure is not an option
by that point
in the apollo 13 mission they'd had a
crew member pull out who had suspected
measles and they're like you can't go
into space if we think you might get
sick so they'd had a member of the crew
had to be swapped out and replaced with
somebody else would they have had a
backup crew standing by if they weren't
prepared for failure well obviously they
were prepared they'd had an engine shut
down the um the saturn v which was the
rocket that took apollo to the moon was
remarkable it's the only rocket that's
never exploded it's never blown up on
launch which is actually pretty
astonishing as rockets go um it had five
of these huge satin engines and one of
them just went nah not today and you're
like we're going to the moon come on
could we go to the moon with only 80 of
our engines they went yeah sure you can
we'll just fire the others for a bit
longer it'll be absolutely fine
and at that point in the apollo program
they had had thousands of component
failures test failures ranging from you
know relatively trivial components going
wrong under test conditions to a fire on
the launch pad that actually killed
three of the astronauts on a mission
that became known as apollo 1. so
failure was very much on the table so
what is this line you know failure is
not an option the apollo saturn launch
vehicle was built to 99.9 reliability
that was the tolerance they engineered
things to you know how many parts it had
six million
so 99.9 meant you only got 6 000
failures on every mission
and that's normal you know that is that
definition of success is 6 000 failures
permission is probably good enough so to
understand
what we mean here by success and failure
you need to kind of take a step back
you're like okay we have a
single hydraulic pressure valve that
stopped working that failed take a step
back but the whole fuel pump system well
that's got another pressure valve so
that keeps working what if the whole
fuel pump system stops working we'll
take another step back we have multiple
fuel pump systems those are still going
we take another step back all the fuel
pump systems are out well let's take
another step back the rocket is still
functional on some level just we can't
use that particular engine assembly and
uh one of the kind of primary drivers of
this what would become known as systems
thinking uh was this woman margaret
hamilton
she led the development team that
created the software the computer and
the guidance system that took apollo to
the moon and back and uh she has this
fantastic quote she said after a while
you begin to think in terms of modeling
all these things as one system part of
it is software part of it is people wear
part of it is hardware now
the mission statement if you like the
user story if you're into the whole
agile product thing that took apollo to
the moon was john f kennedy rice
university 1962 we believe that this
nation should commit itself before this
decade is out to landing a man on the
moon and returning him safely to the
earth now that is one hell of a user
story
you know one there's a deadline the end
of this decade yeah that's fine he
doesn't say how we're going to do it he
doesn't say who's going to do it's like
yeah we're just going to do this thing
by this date you go and figure it out
and you know the main rationale behind
that they needed a massive propaganda
victory over the soviet union and
landing somebody on the moon looked like
the best way of doing it now
when
was that story actually delivered
because you talk about you know
definitions of success and failure
before the decade is out land a man on
the moon return him safely to the earth
well they launched on july the 16th
they landed on july the 20th that was
the day although in some places on earth
it was already july 21st so july 20th is
they landed on the moon but then
everyone always forgets the other part
of the acceptance criteria returning him
safely to the earth because they didn't
get back to earth for another four days
july 24th is when they actually splashed
down but then they had to spend three
weeks in quarantine in case they'd
brought back moon covert or anything so
maybe returning him safely to the earth
maybe that took another couple of weeks
um by the way i've always uh there's a
game my friends and i used to play
sometimes where like can you change
history using the smallest number of
characters and someone suggested what if
there had been a comma in this news
headline like how much would that have
changed astronaut land on the moon they
collect rocks plant and flag all right
well
that would have been fun
a couple of months after this apollo 12
became the second mission to land on the
moon but it very nearly didn't uh but 50
seconds after launch apollo 12 got
struck by lightning twice now uh
i want you to imagine what this must
have been like you and your two
crewmates so you got three of you in
this tiny little capsule about the size
of a compact car and you are on top of
two million litres of highly explosive
rocket fuel on your way to the moon
there is a flash there is a bang all the
lights go out you're like oh this might
be bad
but nasa had a procedure they're like
okay now the first thing that they
noticed that all these people on the
ground monitoring all of the different
systems which were part of the the
apollo saturn uh you know launch vehicle
and they're looking through all these
different things and one of them says
hey
i think maybe the problem we've got here
is that the the ship is fine you know
the rocket's absolutely fine but the
equipment that tells us it's fine has
stopped working and we can switch that
over they had an entire backup
conditioning system this is the the guy
who figured out this guy called john
aaron and uh if you look closely at this
famous picture of margaret hamilton she
is sitting underneath the control panel
on the apollo command con command module
and that command module down in the
bottom right hand corner just above
where her hand is there it has this set
of switches and one of those switches is
signal conditioning equipment do you
want to use the primary or the auxiliary
power system so the entire kind of
telemetry that the astronauts use to
tell the rockets okay they're like well
this might stop working so we've got a
switch in here that we can use to switch
it over and they did they switched the
thing across and it worked lights came
back on they got into orbit they're like
we're just gonna kind of go around earth
just once or twice just to make sure
everything's okay
and it was fine it checked out two
lightning strikes absolutely fine off
they went they became the second crew to
actually set foot on the moon now
if it hadn't worked they had loads and
loads of options up to end including the
launch escape system which was basically
designed if the rockets started blowing
up it would fire the command module off
the top of it it would parachute down in
a field next to the launch site and
they'd probably be okay they never had
to use this this was never tested but
you know this is the the whole point
about this the system's thinking is
looking at every single component every
level of the system and going with this
bit doesn't work
take a step back does the whole thing
still operate no okay we'll better put
in another one of those take another
step back take another step back and so
we have this kind of uh fractal
relationship between systems from the
smallest you know hydraulic valve to
individual crew members to individual
launch criteria all the way up to john f
kennedy's mission statement which is we
want to land on the moon and return
safely to the earth now
what you have to realize then about that
uh that famous quote is this is the
context we've never lost an american in
space we're sure as hell not gonna lose
one on my watch failure is not an option
success has been reframed because
suddenly they're like we might become
the first mission to actually have
american astronauts die in space that's
not allowed to happen we're not landing
on the moon that's gone you know this is
not going according to plan but
we are not going to lose one on my watch
that's what he's talking about in this
context now apollo 13 actually ended up
being a triumph they didn't land on the
moon but the media attention around it
was you know astonishing as some people
called it nasa's finest hour
but by then everyone was kind of getting
bored you know there's another famous
quote in the movie they make gun of the
moon look about as much fun as taking a
trip to pittsburgh um they beaten the
russians to the moon the space race was
over nasa was starting to wind down the
program public interest in space flight
was waning they needed something
exciting to recapture it and they came
out with this
the uh now this is not the space shuttle
because there was never anything called
the space shuttle this is the space
transportation system which consists of
three sub-systems the orbiter the
external tank and the solid rocket
booster but nasa can call it whatever
they like to all of us who kind of grew
up watching this this was the space
shuttle
now the shuttle incorporated
all kinds of innovations from apollo it
also incorporated all kinds of new stuff
from aviation from aerospace and one of
the things that it incorporated it was
the first spacecraft to use a
fly-by-wire system the pilot the
commander they would move the stick the
stick would say to the computer hey
someone moved a stick and the computer
would be like all right what does that
mean it means move that a little bit
trim that a little bit turn that engine
up a little bit and that's how they
literally flew the the um shuttle into
orbit and then how they landed it like
an airplane now to understand the
thinking behind the space shuttle
guidance computer system
the computers basically got it into
space and got it back again and during
launch and during re-entry and landing a
computer glitch could have been really
really bad so to understand the
engineering we need to think about how
do computer systems fail because failure
happens in three different ways you open
your laptop you try and open a website
and you have an immediate that didn't
work error message straight away you
tried to do that it was unsuccessful
sorry here is an error message might be
helpful might not be helpful or you have
the you try to do something
and nothing happens and nothing happens
and nothing happens and nothing happens
then eventually you're gonna get you
know what i'm pretty sure this thing is
broken request time that and if you
don't make the call your browser makes
the call or your internet connection
something goes
we expected a response by now but we
didn't get one this is a failure
condition
but then you have the thing where you
open your laptop and you try and read
the news and uh you get something that
kind of looks like plausible responses
but maybe there's something wrong with
it like spongebob invades luxembourg
really
now when this happens what you do is
you're like that's not right maybe uh
maybe my laptop's been hacked maybe this
website's been hacked let me check it
against another source of truth so you
get your phone out and you're like all
right well according to my phone biden
signed a new tax deal let me check my
ipad okay tax deal tax deal something's
wrong with my laptop because it says
that spongebob invaded luxembourg but
maybe
your phone says mexico won eurovision
laptop says spongebob invades luxembourg
and your tablet says that brexit
opportunities have been found on mars
at this point you have to conclude that
the entire internet news delivery system
has become unstable and so you go and
you get your news from something else
you find a different authority for the
result that you need for that exercise
and that's what the space shuttle
designers did they anticipated these
three different failure modes
the shuttle flew with five of these
this was an ibm ap101 it's basically a
mainframe in a box about this big they
had five of these computers on board and
four of them ran exactly the same
software bite for byte copies of the
same code so they hired a contractor
they said build us a guidance system for
the space shuttle they implemented that
they copied this and these four
computers ran with the same input output
bus and the same timing clock so in
theory they always gave you exactly the
same responses to everything at exactly
the same moment and if one of them
didn't
you could conclude that that one just
that one piece of hardware had developed
a fault and you could take it out of the
loop and you could rely on the other
three
if one of those then started giving you
incorrect data you could take that one
out of loop but then you are only left
with two
and then if they start to disagree you
don't know which one's correct and so at
that point there was a what's called a
uh
mission abort condition basically man if
you lost any computer you turn around
and you start coming home right now
because if you've lost one you can't
afford to lose another one because if
you lose another one you're down to two
and then if they start disagreeing you
don't know what to do with it you're
going to be in a lot of trouble but if
all four of those primary computers
suddenly start giving you completely
different information
they would fail over to the fifth
and the fifth was running the same
software or no it was running software
built by a different contractor to the
same specification
there was no relationship between the
two two completely independent suppliers
because their risk analysis calculation
said even if there is a catastrophic bug
in both of these implementations the
odds of it being in the same place are
effectively zero so even if one of these
computer systems has a catastrophic bug
that's going to go off halfway during
launch
the other one probably doesn't have a
problem in the same place
which is a really interesting way of
kind of hedging your bets and
acknowledging that neither of these
systems is going to be perfect now
for the first couple of missions the
shuttle actually flew with a sixth
computer on board that wasn't running
anything because the reasoning was if
they lost one
they could patch the code across put it
onto the sixth one get that plugged in
up and running and that one would take
over so that they would not have to
abort the mission they eventually
stopped carrying it because after six
missions it had never been used and you
know the congress senate the people who
control the budget for nasa were like
you need to stop flying spare parts
because it's costing the taxpayer like a
million dollars per pound to send spare
parts into space and you're never using
them now as it turns out
the shuttle never had a computer failure
the computer on board the shuttle was
100 reliable
but
there were other things caused by this
attitude this attitude to risk of that
didn't go wrong so we should stop
worrying about it because it didn't go
wrong last time so it's probably going
to be fine which would go on to have
really tragic consequences now human
beings suck at risk
we are terrible at anticipating how
risky certain kinds of behavior are
anyone here afraid of flying
because you know lots of people they're
fine flying they don't like it and then
they land at the airport they get in a
taxi and they're like ah the danger is
over so i'm not doing you any favors
when i tell you you are way more likely
to get killed in the taxi than you are
in the airplane because road accidents
in terms of you know per hours of
participation being a passenger in a car
is way more risky than being a passenger
in an aircraft but
we associate being in a car with
familiar everyday stuff we do every day
you know we go in our car we drive to
school we drive to the shops we drive
all over the place we go see family it's
just the car you know it's not dangerous
whereas going in planes most people
don't go in planes very often so when
they think about planes they think about
the stories they've seen on the news and
on hollywood movies and tv about
aviation disasters and because those are
professional storytellers trying to
scare the crap out of you
that resonates and so we think cars are
safe because our experience of cars is
based on
what we do and we think about aircraft
and our experience of aircraft is often
based on stuff we've seen happen to
somebody else and of course it doesn't
make headlines unless it's bad you know
no one ever goes on the news and says 80
000 flights landed perfectly safe that's
not news that's just business as usual
you know so
when you think about something like uh
installing a new piece of software
you're rolling out an upgrade across a
whole network of systems and uh it is
kind of part of the process that
everyone gets ready like we're doing a
big upgrade you know it might go wrong
we're going to plan for this we've
planned for that we've got a backup
we've got a failover strategy we've got
all this kind of stuff and you think
through all of the failure conditions
and come up with a plan for what you're
going to do if those things happen you
roll out the new system there are
probably some bugs you say to all your
users like you see anything weird we
just launched this big upgrade you see
anything weird just let us know so we
can jump on and we can fix it but then
after a couple of weeks you fixed most
of the things that you didn't think
about
everything kind of settles down and
that's when things get interesting there
is a bathtub curve shape which is a plot
of the number of failures or defects you
get in a system against the operating
lifespan of that system and it's called
a bathtub because it looks like this
comes down goes across and goes up again
and
this hides something really important
there are three kinds of defects that
you get in systems you get what are
called early life cycle defects this is
in mechanical systems these are the
parts that weren't installed properly in
software this is the edge cases that you
missed that you never realized until you
went into production that that was even
a thing that could happen then there are
what are called the random defects which
is just stuff goes wrong every day for
no readily apparent reason ah this
computer doesn't work why not i don't
know it's been working for four years
today it decided it's not going to work
all right we better replace it and then
we get end-of-life defects now in
mechanical systems this is where pieces
start to wear out you know bearings wear
out valves wear out hinges wear out in
software this is the point where people
stop giving a crap because they're going
to do a new one any day now and so i
would yeah we're going to stop
maintaining that we're not going to fix
that bug it's all right the new system
will be here in six months nine months
two years five years
is anyone familiar with brandenburg
airport in berlin that was supposed to
open in 2008 and it didn't and it didn't
and it didn't and every six months i
guess somebody in berlin must have been
like we should extend the metro system
to tagle airport and they went no no
brandenburg's opening any day now and so
for 14 years the main airport to the
capital of germany you had to get the
metro as far as you could get off and
wait in the rain next to the lawnmower
shop for a bus to take you to the
airport and that's a classic example of
now this airport is end of life and it
ran on for another 14 years but in
software this is why systems eventually
you know software doesn't wear out we
get unsupported operating systems we get
we can no longer install the latest
security patches for this component or
that component but really this is just
we decide that the software is no longer
being maintained and then things start
to kind of go downhill so we have these
three different kinds of defects
and this is the kind of attitude we have
to it the new system hey stay alert
watch out things might be weird relax
and everything's fine and this
means that during the relax everything's
fine
we think the number of defects is going
to continue going down because we think
that curve is going to go all the way to
zero but it doesn't and this gives us a
lax attitude to failure when the space
shuttle was first commissioned and
launched there was an extensive set of
launch control protocols and criteria
and one of those was the space shuttle
weather launch commit criteria you
couldn't launch the shuttle if it was
raining you couldn't launch the shuttle
if the wind speed was above a certain
level if there was lightning if the
maximum temperature was above a certain
level but they didn't have a minimum
temperature there was nothing in there
about it being too cold to launch the
space shuttle and in uh february 2000
february 1984
they did a launch where it was 13
degrees celsius outside now this is in
florida which you know you don't think
of florida or somewhere that gets cold
it's 13 celsius and they're like is this
safe and they talk to all the suppliers
and all the suppliers are like
it might be safe
we don't know
and yeah they got into this weird thing
there's so much pressure to keep flying
the shuttle because they need to keep
putting payloads into orbit launching
satellites because that's where the
money for the space program kind of came
back in from that these uh you know the
suppliers the contractors who built the
components were like we don't think it's
a good idea but we're not going to be
the ones you blame for stopping it so
put down on the record that we thought
it was a bad idea but then you go and do
it anyway so they launched 13 degrees
off they went a year later january 1985
it was 10 degrees outside when they
launched the shuttle and they said is
this a good idea and people like well it
went okay at 13.
like i guess 10 might be all right it's
not a good idea but and there's this
kind of you know yolo try it and see
what happens
and then january 1986
it was three degrees the space shuttle
launched and the rubber seals on those
external rocket boosters turned out they
were brittle below five degrees celsius
the rubber stopped flexing it would stay
fixed in place it wouldn't seal the gaps
there was a catastrophic explosion
destroyed the spacecraft killed all
seven astronauts on board now the person
who correctly identified the cause of
that explosion was this guy uh richard
feynman the nobel prize winning
physicist he was invited to be a kind of
external advisor on the investigatory
board for the challenger disaster and
one of the things his observations nasa
did not like what he had to say about
this but they published his observations
as an appendix to the official report
and one quote from that
he said we found that the certification
criteria used in flight readiness often
develop a gradually decreasing
strictness the argument that the same
risk was flown before without failure is
accepted as an argument for the safety
of accepting it again
now has any of you uh who drive a car
you ever had a problem with the seat
belt on your car
and it just won't do up so you book it
into the shop but like they can't see
you till next week and so you go out
without your seatbelt on once and it's
really scary and you're like i'm going
to die and you don't die and you get
home and the next day you're like oh i
need to go to the store uh all right oh
there's seat belts still bringing well i
didn't die yesterday and by the end of
the week you've been driving around
without a seatbelt the whole week and
you're like i don't get the big deal
about the seat belt you know i've done
it for a week i'm absolutely fine and of
course we don't wear seat belts for
driving we wear seat belts for crashing
because that's when they help but if
you're not crashing it's difficult you
have to keep obeying the criteria
even though the circumstances they were
developed for are not actually in effect
right now now
when we think about applying these same
kind of lessons to the way that we
design and build software the attitude
to risk this idea of it didn't go wrong
last time so maybe we're being too
careful we're not worrying about it we
live in a remarkable age where thanks to
you know cloud infrastructure we don't
need to worry about things until just
before they go wrong you know with
modern cloud systems you get unexpected
load it's like being able to as your car
is going into the concrete bridge you're
like ah crap time to buy seat belts and
you put your credit card and boom there
it is just before you hit we can do this
you know we have the ability to go our
building's on fire quickly amazon fire
extinguishers and we can provision all
this kind of infrastructure within
minutes you know sometimes um i've been
working long enough that i remember if
we thought we were going to have a
traffic spike three months earlier you
would order more servers
and you'd have to kind of eyeball how
big do we think it's going to get this
christmas all right we better get
another dell power edge with like the 16
gigs of ram and it would come in a box
six weeks after you ordered it you'd put
it in a rack you'd get it up and running
and it'd sit there and it would do
nothing and you'd hope that when the
spike came one you'd hope it came
because otherwise you wasted all that
money on a server you didn't need and
you'd hope it wasn't any bigger than you
were expecting or you'd wish you'd
bought a bigger server today we're like
nah just scale it up that's absolutely
fine now
we can design systems that are
tremendously resilient we have a reverse
proxy that's like we're actually going
to replicate everything here across two
geographic zones and each one's got a
load balancer with a bunch of web
servers we've got active active
replication the single point of failure
that i've seen in more cloud systems
than anything else is the mastercard at
the bottom that's paying the bill
because you can have as much replication
and web servers and database shards and
everything but the second amazon can't
get your money they start switching
things off and for a long time there was
no way of saying actually here are all
the different credit cards we can
possibly think of um some of the worst
downtime incidents in my own career have
been caused by corporate mastercard
limits so
you need to anticipate the things that
could go wrong and if you look at the
history of massive engineering failures
that make the international news
headlines in almost every case it's
people who thought it was going to be
fine because they were no longer taking
a vigilant attitude to risk and the most
recent example of this
is the british post office
in 1995 post office limited which is the
private company that runs the postal
system in the uk um they commissioned a
new i.t system called horizon there was
a contractor working for i think fujitsu
siemens were the the contractor who were
coordinating this they ran a pilot
scheme in 1999 they rolled that horizon
across 10 000 post office branches and
within a couple of days the staff in
these offices started saying they were
reporting discrepancies the numbers
weren't adding up um the money and the
till didn't match the money in the
computer system
now
i want you to imagine you've just rolled
out a new it system across 10 000 sites
and the people who've been working in
those branches for 10 15 20 years they
are saying to you your computer system
is reporting the wrong numbers the money
is not adding up you need to fix it what
would you do
because you know what they did
they prosecuted them for stealing
they turned around and went no the
computer system is right you will give
the money back or you will go to
jail and i mean it sounds funny it's
true it is the most disgusting you know
uh miscarriage of justice employees were
told if you pay back the missing money
then we will not give you a criminal
record people cashed in their life
savings people mortgage their homes
some people couldn't they were
prosecuted they had charges pressed
against them some of them went to prison
in 2019
550 post office branch managers filed a
class action lawsuit against the post
office limited which was eventually
settled for 58 million to 58 million
pounds now in the transcript of that
lawsuit uh this lady this is paula
reynolds the chief executive of post
office limited who's also a church of
england reverend until they told her she
had to stop does she look evil
she said the message the board and i
were consistently given by fujitsu from
the highest levels of the company was
that while like any i.t system horizon
was not perfect and had a limited life
span it was fundamentally sound not
perfect limited lifespan but you're
going to jail because the computer
doesn't agree with the amount of money
left in your shop at the end of the day
the judge the high court judge who
presided over it honorable mr justice
fraser he said the post his defense
amounted in reality to bear assertions
and denials that ignore what actually
occurred the 21st century equivalent of
maintaining that the earth is flat now
british high court justices they are
normally very very dry this is like him
completely losing it in the judgment you
know
now this has finally been overturned the
convictions have been overturned
it's they're blaming it on corrupt data
now you know if we accept that data is
imperfect then surely the people making
decisions based on the corrupt data are
the ones who should be liable this has
gone down as the biggest one of the
biggest miscarriages of justice in
british legal history now you know given
the consequences of the decision i find
it unbelievable that the people
responsible trusted the new computer
system over the word of their own staff
across this many incidents across this
many different disconnected branches and
situations and people now
if you've ever worked any kind of help
desk you've had the thing where you know
the person on the other end is lying
because they ring you up and they say
where are my files and you say uh what
files and i like the files that i put on
the network and you're like
you didn't put any files on the network
but you're like you know what all right
i'll i'll uh all right let me go and
check the backups and you put the phone
down you make a cup of coffee you look
out the window for a bit and then you
phone them back i'm sorry i've checked
the backups there's no trace of the
files but you know this kind of stuff
happens all the time people are like i
definitely put the files through i
definitely submitted this i definitely
clicked save and you're like
i didn't yeah you know but if someone
was going to jail i'd actually check the
backups you know if someone was going to
jail i'd be like no let's go through
every single line here let me check your
hard drive i'll check the networks i
check all the stuff and at the end of it
if it was literally one person saying
they'd done this and a computer system
saying done something i'd be like we
don't know i wouldn't be like you're
lying and now you will go to prison for
it now
sometimes the consequences of not
anticipating the role of the end user in
a system can have tragic results but
sometimes they just have every day
frustrating results um how many of you
are familiar with this uh you know the
thing where you go to log into a website
and it texts you a code and this is good
this is two-factor authentication
security is important i have a friend
who lives in central london not far away
from where i am she has no mobile phone
reception in her house because it's an
ancient victorian building that's kind
of down in a valley so for her to sign
into online banking she goes onto the
thing types in her laptop grabs her
phone and has to run out into the street
around the corner and hold her phone up
and when she gets the code she has to
run back in and type it in because the
code is only good for 60 seconds and
the people
who built the system it works perfectly
you send the text message you check the
text message you type it into the
website awesome you know works every
time and you say to them yeah but what
about someone living in a victorian
house in a valley and they're like
that's not a software problem we can't
fix that because it's not systems
thinking it's software thinking they
haven't taken that step back and gone
all right the phone works the network
works the website works
what else might cause this thing to fail
any system every system i've ever built
has gone into production and within
about i don't know a week someone has
thrown something at it that i'm like wow
we didn't think of that happening and i
found this video recently which
demonstrates this beautifully this is
the tesla autopilot
going down a road going traffic lights
traffic lights traffic lights traffic
lights traffic lights because
it's following a truck full of traffic
lights
and it never occurred to anyone that
there might be traffic lights on the
public highway for a reason other than
traffic control um i've seen similar
things a lot of uh ice cream trucks
around where i live they have a stop
sign painted on the back so that you
know not to kind of run over little kids
who are getting ice cream after school
and the teslas will pick them up and
they'll stop
and ice cream chocolate coffee and it'll
start again and it'll stop
um
now
end users are
frustrating because they don't use the
system right like they are ingenious you
give them a tool and they will figure
out ways of using that tool
that were absolutely not how you
intended it to be used because end users
are ingenious they got stuff to do and
they are going to figure out a way of
doing their jobs um i had a couple of
friends years ago who worked for a
company who made laboratory equipment
who were paranoid about industrial
espionage to the extent that they
blocked attachments you could not send
email attachments in or out of the
company and they got engineers all over
the world going into universities and
hospitals to fix you know really really
quite expensive sophisticated kit and
they're like i need a firmware patch so
they'd phone one of their buddies back
in the office and be like hey um i need
the 27.6 firmware patch for this one
and what they do is their buddy back in
the office would sign into hotmail
go into the drafts folder compose an
email attach the attachment
and not send it and then they'd ring you
back and go hey it's in the drafts
folder of the shared mailbox that every
engineer in the company knew the
password for they never sent the email
because that would be breaking the rules
the fact there's a hotmail drafts folder
full of firmware upgrades and stuff well
no one said that was illegal so you know
we are playing but now sometimes
technology goes wrong
in ways that looks like a bug until you
dig a little deeper
this thing here is a it's a mathematical
shape called a lorenz attractor it's uh
comes from this wonderful field of chaos
theory and fractal geometry which is
something i really love working with and
it's named after this guy edward lorenz
he was a he was a meteorologist he was a
weather forecaster he was one of the
first people to look at whether you
could use computers to predict the
weather and he did it using this
it's a computer called the royal mcb lg
p30 had 128k of ram
120 kilohertz cpu clock it weighed about
350 kilos and he built a little weather
simulation system that ran on this thing
and uh
his weather simulation he just plotted
metrics of atmospheric temperature at
different points uh somewhere on a kind
of little simulated world we're talking
really really simple simulation here and
then he'd run his simulation and it
would print a graph
and i say print it was a teleprinter so
it would actually print the temperature
by just going space space space dot
space space space base dot so we'd get
these little graphs and one day the
story goes that uh he got halfway
through a simulation the computer
crashed so he took the print out of the
numbers typed them back in and set the
simulation running again and it went the
same up to a point and then it deviated
and it started doing something different
and he's thinking
this is a computer like where is the the
idiosyncrasy where does the difference
come from
and what he worked out is that
internally the royal mcb was storing six
decimal places of precision but it was
only printing three of them
and it was that difference that point
zero zero zero six seven eight
that led to him starting to discover
what would become known as chaos theory
systems which are incredibly sensitive
to tiny tiny differences in their
initial input he says that he knew that
day the day he discovered it that we
were never going to be able to do
long-range weather forecasting using
computers and the intervening 50-60
years have basically proved him right
but that little computer glitch that
difference between the printout and the
memory spawned a completely new wing of
science chaos fractal geometry all that
stuff kind of emerged from that
discovery now
if you've ever sat out in a field on a
sunny day and you've kind of looked up
and seen clouds and your brain is trying
to fill them in and turn them into
shapes
what is going on there is we have
pattern recognition routines that have
evolved into the way our brains work we
can recognize friends we can recognize
predators we recognize in a family our
social community and we have started
teaching computers to do the same thing
by taking a convolutional neural network
which we don't quite know how it works
but we know what it does and uh we feed
it a whole stack of labeled photographs
and it goes through and
it's you know the terminology here is
difficult figures out is maybe the wrong
word it's that famous ed edgar dies for
a quote you know asking if a computer
can think is like asking if a submarine
can swim but we feed a bunch of data
into that thing and eventually what we
get at the other end is a system that
refuses to play animation which is
always entertaining there we go
and uh comes out the other end and goes
oh yeah i've decided that this thing
here is there we go
that by the way is a feature of the m1
mac with apple silicon and sometimes it
doesn't play powerpoint videos um it
does a lot of other things well but that
one doesn't work and i still haven't
figured out why so we've built something
that can recognize dogs which might not
sound like it's difficult like you know
how difficult is it to tell the
difference between a dog and a cupcake
might be harder than you think
but then
the end users come along and they're
like ah someone built a dog detector
here now uh i was out in in ruffin on
sunday and uh you know there's a lot of
people take their dogs up to reference
and i quite like dogs and so i i run the
the dog detector over this photograph i
took of refund and it comes back and it
says sorry we didn't find any dogs in
this picture but then i do the end user
thing i'm like turn the dog detector
around
and turn it into a dog amplifier and
turn it up
and the computer goes um what are you
doing and i'm like turn it up and it
says are you sure
and i say turn it up and he goes this is
a horrible idea i like turn it up there
we go look
and i'm like
increase the amplification he's going
this is a horrible this is not what the
neural network was designed to do and
i'm like no come on maximum power
and through the creative misuse of
serious computer science we have created
a new form of art that can take
photographs of something completely
innocuous and turn them into weird kind
of psychedelic dream sequences with lots
of noses and eyes and teeth everywhere
now
i love the misuse and misapplication of
technology because it is so ingenious
sometimes it leads to delightful whimsy
sometimes it leads to hotmail drafts
folders full of firmware updates and
stuff but sometimes it can lead to some
real social change
i grew up in africa
i spent my childhood in zimbabwe i was
born in kenya we used to go on holidays
when i was a kid where we'd get in the
car and we would just drive for three or
four hours down roads that look like
this you know no civilization no tarmac
no street lights nothing and uh every
once in a while you'd see in the
distance there'd be a little hut by the
side of the road somewhere and it was
always painted bright red and white
hand-painted coca-cola logo and uh
there'd be someone in the i don't know
how but they always had like a crate of
ice-cold coca-cola and uh i went back to
africa a couple years back for my
cousin's wedding i was in zambia and
there were bits of it that haven't
changed in 20 years except the red and
white hand-painted signs don't say
coca-cola anymore they say vodacom
because uh since the turn of the
millennium africa has experienced a
communications revolution trying to run
regular telephone networks across africa
was never gonna work because you need
three things to do that one you need a
dense population of people two those
people need to have a lot of money and
three the government has to have your
back if someone turns up in the night
and steals all of your wire for various
complicated reasons
africa is very sparsely populated a lot
of the people who make up the population
are not terribly affluent they don't
have a huge amount of disposable income
and uh government corruption is rife
across parts of southern and sub-saharan
africa which means you spend a fortune
laying copper cable along the side of
the road you come back in the morning
the cable is gone because someone has
taken it and sold it for scrap and so
for whatever reason africa didn't take
off until cellular networking came along
because mobile phones are a game changer
you don't need the infrastructure you
can put a bunch of masts up on top of a
hill and suddenly three or four hundred
people can be reached by that one cell
phone tower
if you went here this is nairobi capital
city of kenya if you'd visited here
around about the year 2000 uh you know
nairobi is a modern city restaurants you
know banks entrepreneurship there are
even a couple of tech startups running
out of there as early as 2000 but you
could drive a couple of miles outside of
nairobi and you'd find people who had
never made a phone call let alone seen a
computer people who had no idea what the
internet was or why it would matter to
them so as they started rolling out
cellular networking and putting in the
infrastructure one of the challenges
that they had there was how do you roll
out mobile phone networks to people who
don't have bank accounts
eighty percent of the population in
kenya
pardon me is what was known as unbanked
they don't have any kind of banking no
savings nothing they live cash in hand
and what kind of happened is each
village somebody would get a mobile
phone and effectively they'll become
like a little start-up business for them
they'd have a nokia phone and if you
need to make a call you'd go and see
them
you'd give them a little little bit of
cash they'd let you make a call and when
they got enough cash they would get on
their bicycle and they'd go into town
and they'd buy a vodafone top-up card or
a vodacom top-up club they'd buy credit
everything was pre-pay because nobody
had a bank account then the users
realized
that the thing you needed wasn't
actually the top-up card it was the code
the serial number that would activate
the credit and this spawned something
remarkable because a lot of places the
kids would uh you know grown-up kids
would go and work in the cities and
their parents would be way out in the
country in the villages and so someone
would get a job in nairobi they'd go
they'd be working in a factory working
in a bar or something and previously to
send money home either they would have
to make the trip themselves take them
about four or five days
or they would put the money in an
envelope and try and find somebody they
trusted who was going in the right
direction and hope it got there but when
they figured out that they could
transfer mobile phone credit they would
ring the telephone person in their
parents village and they'd be like uh
hey i got 10 000 shillings of top up for
you and they'd read the number out
so they take their cash from their job
they'd buy the card they'd read the
number at guy back in the village or a
lady back in the village would top up
their phone with 10 000 shillings and
the next day when mom comes in for
groceries they'll be like hey
your son sent me 8 000 shillings minus a
you know consideration because you've
got to grease the wheels of commerce
but this was a game changer because it
meant there was suddenly a reliable way
of transferring money that didn't
involve carrying cash now
shortly after that they launched a
friends and family system which meant
you could use a text message to send top
up from your phone to someone else's
phone now this isn't telephone banking
this is literally just transferring
mobile phone minutes of call time credit
but suddenly people started using this
as a form of currency they would you
know go into the store they'd buy some
groceries they would pay by sending a
text message with 500 shillings of
credit store keeper would go out for
beer after work they'd buy their beer
with credit next day the guy running the
bar needs to get his bicycle fixed he
goes to see the place that fixes
bicycles sends him a text message
there's the credit it starts circulating
people are using this as a de facto form
of currency now
this is the point where vodacom might
have gone
this was a terrible idea we launched
mobile phones in kenya and no one's
making any phone calls you know this is
not what we designed the system for but
that's not what they did what they did
instead
was they went there's a really
interesting opportunity here maybe we
can actually take what is already
happening here that you know this has
been created by end users innovating
with the tools we gave them and turn
this into something that we can actually
use and so the product that they created
was a thing called pesa mobile payments
m for mobile uh pacer is the swahili
word meaning money and pacer had a
network of authorized agents so there'd
be someone in your village who if you
needed to you could take your and pacer
in and you could cash out you could get
proper cash back but most people didn't
they just circulated and pacer airtime
credit and this became the de facto
currency of the entire kenyan economy
within about two or three years it has
represented
i saw recently i set a path out of
poverty for something like a quarter of
a million people just because they had a
reliable way of receiving money and
hanging onto it that didn't involve cash
now this only worked in kenya they tried
to roll it out in afghanistan a few
years later didn't take off they tried
it in romania they tried it in india
pakistan tanzania it's still there's a
couple of places in africa ghana they
use it a little bit tanzania they use it
a little bit in uganda it's still
available in kenya it is ubiquitous
trying to shut down pacer in kenya now
would be like telling europe they're not
allowed to use mastercard anymore it's
that relevant and it only exists
because the users used the product wrong
and the managers of the product company
went this is interesting and they didn't
say no we're taking your phones away
they didn't shut the system down they
didn't change the terms and conditions
they learned from what they hadn't
anticipated they looked at something
which could have been construed to be
failure and when actually this is really
interesting there's something here we
could not have anticipated so
go out there you know build the systems
that you build do good work write tests
make sure stuff works cover everything
you can think of but don't ever make the
mistake of thinking that you know better
than your own users because once stuff
goes into production it gets out there
real people start using it failure is
always going to be an option thank you
we have a we have a couple of minutes
for questions folks does anyone have any
questions
if not i know that the next thing on the
program after this is the the party
there will be beers there will be snacks
uh there will be comedy assuming that my
uh co-hosts have finished writing it
well i've been up here talking about
mobile phones and space rockets um stick
around folks enjoy the rest of the
evening enjoy tomorrow if you're not
staying this evening i will see some of
you later on at the party have a great
time
you